this is fun
right i shouldn't have eaten lunch what
was i thinking
hey everyone it's your girl chloe bailey
and these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
so you know we like to set the mood
before we feed our bodies with food for
the soul
so we have the humidifier with essential
oils candles
oh that smells good already
gotta set the tone
ah cauliflower puffs i love these and
we're matching it's the perfect date
it's the perfect first snack i just had
these the other day on the plane i was
going to vegas for grammys and i was
really hungry because i'm vegan there's
limited options for me especially early
in the morning
but i found these bad boys so this is
what in my mind why people love cheese
puffs so much because it tastes like
this
i just had lunch but i can never say no
to food
only bad thing about these
they make your breath stink and
you gotta go to the bathroom because
it's cauliflower
popcorn
there's this inside joe cali and i do
where i'll go ice cream and she goes
popcorn
i don't know if you've seen it if you
have great you get the joke
but i love kettle corn because it's
sweet
and it's a good snack
and like when good tea is happening
around
just eat some popcorn while it's going
down
that's good
i'm a anything snacker anything i can
get my hands on that i can actually eat
i will eat it
lara bar cashew cookie and it's like a
little sweet
a little healthy tasting
but i love it like if i'm trying to be
healthy and look snatched but still have
like a little sweet something
this is really the only flavor i like
they have like a peanut butter and
chocolate one which is good too but this
one's my favorite because it's like
a healthy sugar cookie i'm not a healthy
vegan but i guess majority of vegan
snacks are healthy
it tastes like a cookie to me all the
like healthy healthy vegan snacks you
won't see on this table
thank you
this is my go-to snack if you want to
make me happy no matter the time of the
day get me some watermelon i love it
because watermelon is 95 water so it's
like you're drinking water and you feel
snatched ah yes
mm-hmm
i love watermelon so much i got my dog
common hooked to watermelon i have a
chinese question
he's my baby shout out to common we
named him calm and not after the rapper
but because he's not common he has a
blue eye and a brown eye and he's
hairless and he loves watermelon just
like me
thank you
honey throat coat
water
this is like my go-to drink if i'm in
the studio right before performance
gotta throw those vocal cords babies
this is a secret honey really isn't
necessarily vegan because it comes from
bees even though they aren't harmed or
killed in the process
so i apologize but i do consume honey
and i love it it's my favorite thing in
the whole world and if you watch the
treat me video you see how i'm in the
pool of honey
honey is my favorite thing in the whole
entire world
and then usually i'll get a spoon and
i'll mix it up i love honey so much
sometimes i'll take the packets and just
consume some right before i go on stage
like
this there you have it
a coated throat for singing and speaking
okay so i hope i don't sound like a fool
pronouncing these ashwagandha gummies
it's from the ashwagandha root it's my
favorite thing in the whole world i can
have them they're gummies no gelatin
and they help with stress and anxiety
ladies and gentlemen
that's what i got meals for i took two
this morning aren't they cute
it just calms you down
it tastes like berries it tastes like
berry gummies
sometimes days are constantly going and
going and you have to learn how to kind
of take care of yourself and life can
kind of get the best of you sometimes
and you just need a little
just a little chill pill it's literally
like a chill gummy
now this is my favorite of the favorite
next to watermelon
coconut milk yogurt because i can't
really have yogurt as a vegan it tastes
like ice cream it tastes sweet
i love acai bowls with a bunch of
granola
so i feel like this kind of gives me the
same
enjoyment and pleasure
i will have like three of these a day
and it has it still has the probiotics
in it
for us
vegans
um
this was my favorite
and it's crunchy
and sweet
i have like
15 of these in my fridge right now
[Music]
i'm chloe bailey thanks for hanging out
with me with snack i hope you treated
yourself like i treated myself go check
out treat me right now it's out
everywhere end the video love you all
[Music]